so welcome to the losers cloud right yes
this movie really proves you know
friendship can conquer or anything even
like homicidal pounds yeah do you guys
think you can conquer anything together
now that you've been through this
experience probably maybe I mean you're
as strong as our characters no this is
this movie freaked me out it's been
taking me a few days to kind of shake
off the idea that every time I wash my
hands and look in the mirror there might
be something like horrifying trying to
get me did you guys get that feeling
after filming like what kind of
practical effects wants that that might
lead you to maybe have some nightmares
or get freaked out during the day I
think we didn't have time for nightmares
because our night like the nightmare of
scariness was going on what we're
shooting with Pennywise so why you go to
sleep that's your piece yes and when you
come to work it's like oh shoot
Pennywise gonna be here somewhere
lurking in the shadows it's like flipped
is like working is the dream well it is
but I mean like working is the dream in
this scenario and then dreaming hold on
wait no I had it it sounded better in my
head deeper very deep how do you guys do
when you're actually watching scary
movies cuz again like for me I was like
oh man I was shifting I was just like I
know what's coming I just don't want to
see it but here we go and you guys are
in it and obviously you're gonna have to
you know you had to watch it so how did
you do the first time you saw it well we
actually haven't seen it what we saw we
saw the rough cut we saw a rough cut
musicmusic fact yeah how do you think
you'd be like who here is the worst with
watching scary movie it's Jeremy
great yeah I was actually having second
thoughts about even watching the movie
in the first place I definitely am happy
I definitely am now but at first I was
like you guys you guys know I'm not
coming just me right now you have to
change
now I'm coming but I know I know I'm
coming yeah yeah you guys like well at
least you have an idea of what you're in
for I mean you were in the thing that's
sure so which is about clowns why do you
think people are so fascinated with or
are like freaked out by clowns
no one's that happy no one is that is
not true
no one saying is that happy yeah it just
seems a little unsettling to be with you
know clowns cuz they're so I don't know
it's gotten everything the white makeup
and you the hallways being really
critical with hammers and yeah what is
what is actually scarier like having to
to go through like this haunted house
set and and be chased by a homicidal
clown or share an onscreen kiss like
what is actually more intimidating Oh
going into spirit kissing I'm looking at
kissing the kissing black oh yeah yeah
right
watching your and thank ya it's kind of
nerve yeah yeah you place this all Jan
okay work that yeah get nice and into it
and wide and I were watching that sounds
weird but we all watch this part was the
feedback yeah we're suckers so good like
that do it alone what what else can you
say after an onscreen kiss like like
especially yeah good job I think that's
the best thing
thanks a lot guys I enjoyed the movie
when you finally see it thanks thanks
good luck with the nightmares over
having after thank you thanks